six o'clock wednesday morning those
stories and more in just a few moments
but first we have some breaking news
metro police on the scene of a homicide
they're doing an investigation there in
the southeast valley this is tropicana
and nellis where we find bianca holmen
with the details
bianca good morning so we know that a
hispanic man in his 60s is dead so he
was shot right here across the street
from whitney library right in front of
the sonoma of sonoma hills apartment
complex and this happened at a bus stop
right after 2 15 in the morning so
police got calls around that time and
then also the technology they used for
shot spotter was also used to
come to this area and that's where they
found
the victim who was shot suffering from
gunshot wounds and then taken to sunrise
hospital so the police right now you can
see they are still canvassing the area
right there in front of
the bus station of the bus stop excuse
me and that's where the shooting took
place we were able to check in with the
police department this morning about the
shooting
right now we have very preliminary
details that are very little
all we know is that there was some type
of altercation that occurred between him
and another male at the bus stop and
during that
altercation
he was shot several times
so police also tell us that they don't
have necessarily an accurate description
of the suspect but they do know that the
man was wearing dark colored clothes so
they're asking for anybody in the area
maybe you were
in these apartments nearby or traveling
in this area and you may have seen
something to please call crime stoppers
so that they can locate that suspect
reporting live bianca holman live local
now